joining me now on the Rich Eisen show is
the man himself Colt McCoy how is life
for you now cold no it's good it's good
you know winning you know makes makes
these weeks and then FL a whole lot
better but what was it like for you just
the circumstances of it obviously being
the texas longhorn legend that you are
and going into that stadium in that
state in that uniform in that game and
performing as you did yeah it was it was
a whole lot of fun you know I'd have
been sick if we lost that game you know
it took me a while to get going and
knock some rust off you know from not
being out on the field you know over the
last couple years but our defense played
outstanding they kept us in the game and
we were able to as an office to make
some plays down the stretch that you
know won the game for us so we are we're
fired up as a huge win for us on the
road in the division and you know
hopefully we can continue this get some
momentum from this and you know carry it
forward now I know that you your your
show again folks are if they don't
already know who you are of course they
do but you're showing off what's in your
DNA which is talking about your team
talking about a team effort talking
about a team win but for you cold again
to to go into Texas Stadium I mean
that's the Dallas Cowboys you're a Texas
Longhorn as the day is long your from
that state and this is a longtime
rivalry I'm sure you grew up watching
some of these games and for you to
perform as you did had to feel in a
certain way as gratifying a win as ever
would you agree with that yeah I'd agree
with that you know it's uh know that
I've had some ups and downs you know
talking about me personally in my career
you know but I wouldn't change any of
the experiences that I've gained you
know I've learned from the things that
that I've done in the past you know I
accept you know what's going on but I
always try to look at the positive and
you know I'm in a great place here with
great coaches great teammates and to be
honest I was buried on the depth chart
to start the season and you know for
things to happen the way they did and
for me
down on the field and you know to play
well in the second half against
Tennessee and get a win and you know
then to play on Monday night in Dallas
and go out there and play well in our
heart team get another victory that's
just huge for me you know I'm just I'm
thankful that I never hung it up i just
kept confidence in myself and in my
coaches and teammates and you know work
hard and you know it was it was a whole
lot of fun very gratifying and I
appreciated it who has been the McCoy
safety nets the team McCoy people that
you've leaned on as you departed
cleveland had a cup of coffee in san
francisco and as you said we're buried
in the depth chart in DC yeah you know
what i have a strong faith and i got a
great family great wife and good people
around me and I'm thankful for them they
know that I could play you know they
know that I never lost my confidence I
was just waiting for you know the next
opportunity to arise and and i'm glad
that i was prepared i'm glad that you
know I stayed focused and you know it's
all good but again you know hats off to
our team this this was huge for us you
know we know we're better than three and
five but we've got our work cut out for
us and to win two in a row and and you
know hopefully we can you know gain some
momentum from this and and really play
well this week Colt I'm sure you're
aware you're not the only McCoy who got
airtime on ESPN on Monday night rider I
know I know I know it's you know some
want some twice that's fine but how long
14 times how about 14 times you where
that's the count apparently it was 14
times huh that your dad and your mom
were on camera I'm sure they didn't I'm
sure they didn't like that too much
either well hey listen court let me tell
you something uh I wouldn't want my mom
and dad on television 14 times e I think
you're speaking for most of most maybe I
have to put a phone call in the stn or
something about that well you know what
I have some people i mean i've been gone
there for 11 years but I you know I
haven't in if you want to I'll lob it at
all I want you but once you pass that
along you got it will let's see if we
can figure that out a little bit lobbing
that call to Bristol before before I let
you go I know your time is limited what
about next week has has this been
discussed about you
you getting the reins against Minnesota
or is this going to be rg3 do you think
yeah we'll see you know you know playing
a late game Monday night you know we
were off yesterday we just got in the
building this morning you know starting
game plan for Minnesota you know I you
know Jay mentioned after the game when
Roberts healthy he'll play so I assume
if he's healthy he'll be ready to go but
if not you know I will you know my
preparation won't change from here on
out you know and it was it didn't really
change before I started playing I'm
going to prepare as if I'm playing every
week and and always be ready to go and
you know I think the most important
thing for us you know internally in our
organization is we just got to find a
way to win we've won two in a row and
and that we really want to keep this
going it's just again remarkable Colt
the sport NFL football especially that
you just never know what's going to
happen and for you to wait your turn as
you did and then get that turn and take
advantage of it I think fans across the
country really plugged into that have
you have you felt that at all maybe a
little bit you know I yeah I felt really
good out there on Monday night you know
I missed some throws early on you know
Dashon is really fast you know I just I
couldn't didn't judge his speed right in
the first half i miss a couple throws
that love to have back but i felt like
as the second half went on and we got in
the fourth quarter and overtime i just
really you know felt back at home I felt
it like I was in the right place and I
was seeing the defense and seeing the
coverages and you know whatever Jay
dialed up I felt like I could execute it
in that to me is a great feeling after
two years of you know sitting on the
bench and watching and learning and
working hard and doing all the things i
need to do to stay ready to to have it
all come to fruition out on the field
Monday night you know I'm very pleased
with that and and you know what the most
important thing like i mentioned earlier
for us is whether I'm playing or robbers
plan and we just want to find a way win
we have a good team here we're well
coached and we just gotta keep it
rolling well and it was not was not lost
on me when a big plate needed to be
called the coach at one time believed in
your legs and at one point on
fourth-and-short believed in your arm
and
and that had to mean something when
you're in the huddle here and those
plays called cold it did it meant a lot
and for him to put the ball in my hands
and over time you know to trust me often
play actions to trust me on you know
some some pocket passes you know i was i
was feeling good you know I know he
trusted me in and huge for us to get a
win thanks Cole appreciate the time like
I said I know you're you gotta run so I
I really appreciate it congrats on the
big win and good luck moving forward all
right thank you you bet that is Colt
McCoy Washington Redskins quarterback
fresh off his big Monday night when
you're on the rich awesome show the rich
eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience